okay so I'm gonna be talking about a a
slightly different space and a
particular solution we came up with four
problem first I want to mention this is
this is work supported by the US Census
Bureau however as noted before it does
not represent a statement by or by the
US Census Bureau this is purely our own
as independent researchers myself Shawn
Merrill is a grad student at Purdue
Keith Merrill is faculty at Brandeis
along with Eric Hanson who's a student
there we have been working with the
American Community Survey which
introduces a different set of challenges
from decennial so the American Community
Survey is much higher dimensionality
what order of 250 attributes being being
collected it's also a sample of the
population which gets rid of some of
these constraint problems we have but
unfortunately not all of them and
starting out with the current processing
approach introduces some additional
challenges so some things we've run into
missing data imputation a lot of these
things aren't filled in and and we'll
get into what this means in a bit that's
the one we're going to be concentrating
on today some other things that come up
it's a stratified sample it's not a
random sample
what satellite sample is a random sample
well okay it's not a uniform random
sample it's all you simple yeah that's
what a that's truly it actually gets
into it so one of the things is they do
some weighting of the sample to conform
to known ground truth values this throws
us some some real wrenches into the
works so but we're just going to
concentrate today on this first one
which is missing data imputation so does
this really impact privacy well if we
think about it
suppose we have a situation like this
and we impute missing data by looking at
characteristics of similar individuals
now there's a couple ways missing data
is imputed one is known characteristics
if you don't answer citizenship but you
say you were born in the US they can
take a pretty good guess that you're a
US citizen but other times they can't do
that and so currently what they will do
is you know impute this missing data
from people who are similar so we have
kind of the dotted you know individual
may be filled in from someone you know
where's the dashed from someone similar
to that and you know assuming those
rules if we said dashed individuals or
blue dotted individuals or brown this
really doesn't impact sensitivity
where we come up with those rules again
could but you know we'll assume it
doesn't but this allocation problem is
different we go to a neighbor and we say
because you're similar to the neighbor
you're you know this increases
sensitivity because if we change the
color of one of those neighbors that now
changes to individuals or potentially
you know more individuals if we have a
you know a situation like this yeah not
likely we hope we hope we're not going
to end up with most of the data being
missing but if you just start with a
simple global sensitivity you can
construct a situation where you get a
dramatic change so we want to avoid this
you can see remove one individual from
the data set everything changes so one
idea let's just say let's not reuse a
donor
once someone has been responsible for
allocation they aren't responsible they
aren't used again interestingly enough
the existing census allocation problem
does something similar to this and we
thought okay wouldn't that be nice turns
out it's not quite that nice I mean you
can see right here we get a very simple
situation where the we get this sort of
an imputation so let's say our query is
the number of blue squares we see
there's four blue squares that we've
imputed from the data now let's take our
neighboring database by removing that
circle we redo our imputation removing
each item after we've done the
imputation from left to right here and
what's happened even though we're only
using each individual once we get this
weird situation where our sensitivity is
actually very high so the graphic the
idea is my neighboring database I
removed one individual and now I impute
this unknown it's missing data by going
to the nearest neighbor which is now
this one instead of the one that I
removed so I impute that value now I say
I don't want to reuse somebody because
that kind of sends my sensitivity off
through the roof so I'm gonna remove
this one from doing the imputation this
needs to be imputed this is now the
nearest available donor this is the
nearest available donor this is the
nearest available donor so using this
simple idea that I'm going to only use a
donor once
does it actually help my sensitivity
so you know it was kind of our initial
thought was hey there's this nice thing
maybe this will help us out no it didn't
you know so we have something where we
can say well global sensitivities hi
using this a simple approach even our
global sense our local sensitivity is
high so you know one solution would be
say you're just going to ignore your
missing data you compute your your
statistics without the missing data
this would give us kind of there our
lowest variance with respect to we're
not basically you know increasing the
amount of noise we add based on this
imputation the problem with this is it
potentially bias as the result is the
data missing uniformly at random history
suggests that that's not the case that
when someone doesn't provide an answer
to a question that there tends to be
some correlation with other factors and
we can end up asking queries where we
end up with a biased result hard to
measure hard to really know that because
the answer the the data we would need to
answer this is missing but people do
some studies to to try to do try to
evaluate this we can compare it with
other things like what a similar query
would be on the decennial census to get
some idea of these things so you know
what we would like to do is we've got
something like this where there is quite
a bit of bias what we'd like to have is
what's a low sensitivity allocation
method we can still keep this as an
approach to reducing the bias and yet
not have the problem of this very high
sensitivity
so what we went with is can we do
something where we can achieve can use
smooth sensitivity your Global's hi we
know using some this simple approach
didn't work but can we come up with an
approach that allows us to get smooth
sensitivity
so what we did is a similar idea we're
gonna go back to the nearest neighbor
but not try imposing this constraint
that you only use something once what we
really need is the idea that a local
change really is local so if if I'm
imputed to the nearest neighbor by
taking the value from the nearest
neighbor removing that value would only
change the nearest neighbor it's not
going to change things elsewhere it
keeps the changes localized the straight
nearest neighbor will do this for us and
what we find is you know typically each
donor is closest to few donees in fact
looking at the ACS public use microdata
set most cases someone with a missing
value there's an exact match on many
criteria with someone else in the data
set at least on the attributes they're
currently using to do this allocation
and the kind of highest exact match
don't eat a donor ratio or you know what
kind of a lower bound on our local
sensitivity is around 4 so this suggests
that smooth sensitivity could work
yeah they're still still a lot to be
worked out to see what it it means so
what's the idea behind smooth
sensitivity the basic idea is that the
neighbors of the current database don't
induce big changes that getting really
high sensitivity situations you have to
get a long ways away from your start and
the so the idea is for some beta greater
than greater than 0 beta smooth
sensitivity is defined in terms of the
local sensitivity and the distance and
it's the maximum of your local
sensitivity as you go farther away but
as you go farther away you get to reduce
that impact by this multiplier
so intuitively as we get farther away
our local sensitivity may go higher but
our smooth sensitivity hopefully goes
down you know assuming this number is
large enough relative to this increase
or decreases rapidly enough relative to
this increase we're able to get this
reduction and kind of the key result out
of mr. Markova and Smith work is that
this gives us epsilon differential
privacy actually they also worked out an
epsilon Delta version we came up with
some of the same things that the N was
coming up with which is when we looked
into this it turned out that the epsilon
Delta really didn't help us that the
there straight epsilon version was
actually giving us nicer results and a
somewhat different way
but and again you know why this is
happening something we didn't get deeply
into the fact that we seem to be getting
better results with the Straight epsilon
made us happy or the yeah the epsilon0
made us happy anyway because then we
don't have to worry about all of the
additional explanation of policy
so what kind of we'll get and get back
to this when we look into how this works
in our specific problem in terms of the
epsilon 0 you're straight epsilon
differential privacy which noise its
will we'll get back into that and go
into but it is the the keshe that you're
that you're talking about there's a
couple of little tweaks we did to get it
to work well for this particular problem
but it builds heavily on this on the
same idea so what we did is said okay
let's let's abstract this problem to
just a straight nearest neighbor
actually while we're going to talk about
it in terms of the one nearest neighbor
it extends to K nearest neighbor for a
variety of functions of how you combine
the K nearest neighbors straightforward
straightforward extension so what we
want is initially we're thinking okay an
upper bound on the smooth sensitivity of
the function of some query on the data
and the allocated values and okay say
we're gonna just show this for count
queries you're counting some subset the
the number of blue squares type of
example over
over over your data allocated with one
nearest neighbor
so to start this out you know what is
what do we mean here in terms of
sensitivity the idea is kind of the
donee change which is the impact on your
count query between two data sets so the
change between those data sets is equal
to the the original data set and then
the change Union you know the set size
that changes so it's basically the the
number of donees that have changed based
on the donor that changes or the donor
changes between these two data sets now
as you go farther away you get more
donors that could change potentially but
basically the idea is the number of
incomplete two tuples that have changed
as you transform the data set and what
we're able to show is certain things
that will happen on this um I somehow
got a character in there that doesn't
belong that G is by hitting the keyboard
randomly so basically at a you know at a
certain distance the sensitivity at that
distance of D is less than or equal to
or is less than the sensitivity a larger
distance and in particular we can bound
this by the distance times the local
sensitivity
this is kind of a key statement but the
idea here is that if you can get a large
change based on one donor at some future
point you can set up the problem in a
way such that you can get a fairly large
change now
yes it's a property of the nearest
neighbor these are specifically
properties of the nearest neighbor and
this allows us essentially to work out
that our donor change is is or that our
as we change the donors we can get an
upper bound on how big this change is
going to be by looking at our local or
local sense to our local sensitivity as
this means we don't actually have to
calculate this exponential number of
sensitivities as we go away now trick is
in order to get that the differential
privacy we need this to be a smooth
upper bound the idea and smooth
sensitivity this needs to be a smooth
upper bound and ok so you know what
we've got here is just getting us an
upper bound
not necessarily smooth so but the idea
is that we can say that our local
sensitivity at some distance is bounded
by our local sensitivity and that means
that we can come up with these bounds on
the local sensitivity at any given
distance as we go farther and farther
away from our current data set
so we have these bounds and now we need
to get to is this idea of a smooth upper
bound
and now we're essentially saying is that
we want take the maximum distance over
these changes and the sensitivity before
we make that change the previous step
and this is where this is where it's
starts getting to be a little bit tricky
the and in fact if you look at smooth
sensitivity the original paper worked
out some beautiful examples and then
there's not a huge number that have been
worked out since then because it it does
turn out to be a difficult thing to get
you know our first idea was a we just do
a greedy algorithm which gets us several
steps out and we say that you know our
maximum change is based
if each step we find the maximum change
will that extend going out it turns out
it's not that simple so here's an
example where we can see in this case
we're imputed
but if we put a donor you know if we put
a donor here it imputes on all these we
get these four
we remove one of the red or the green
and you can see it just changes by one
more but you know if we delete both the
red and the green initially so that was
our initial to was we put something here
we got to change it for the next change
would just be one but
if we instead make our change instead of
adding one in the middle which was the
biggest local change we do
getting all kinds of general things up
here on the screen okay
if we remove both of these to get our to
change of two away we now have six items
that have changed as opposed to five so
we you know we can't quite do that we
were hoping that we would be able to do
this greedy algorithm to go out and
really find the best but what we've
shown is enough to give a smooth
sensitivity because we are able to bound
how big this type of a change could be
and we're able to get this smooth beta
smooth upper bound on it
I'm not going to go into the math on
this it essentially follows from the
original paper except some adjustments
made to how beta is divided to work a
little better for this problem and
you know and then to bring down beta
because that's really your key is
bringing down beta gives you this
steeper drop
but and I'm not going to go into a lot
of the details on the the proof but
basically what we need to show is that
we're getting this beta smooth upper
bound and using those bounds we
previously showed on the the change in
sensitivity as we go farther away we're
able to demonstrate that
leads us into a bunch of different cases
we work out each of these cases and this
gives us our bound on there so what does
this mean what this really means is that
using this mechanism that essentially is
is based on what came out of the
original paper we can get down to an
epsilon of three over two T times log of
6 ya not we'd like to get smaller but at
the minimum we can calculate what sort
of a variance we get
so we're getting something we're using
simple global using global differential
privacy essentially sensitivity is
off-the-charts using smooth sensitivity
something where we can at least show
what you know what we get we in terms of
the variance we see in the answers
and why is this interesting for the
questions how does this impact results
well it gives us higher variance than if
we just ignored the missing data but
potentially reduces the bias now what we
want is to help the policymakers
determine is this an appropriate
mechanism to use should you in in this
case perhaps just say do we ignore the
missing data do we do something where we
can provide differential prep salón
differential privacy while doing the
imputation well it becomes it comes down
to this bias-variance tradeoff so
okay I guess I was expecting a slide
that's farther down we're trying to
empirically evaluate this this is a
little bit difficult because if we look
at the data that we that's publicly
available on this you know or even not
publicly available
what is your ground truth for missing
data the ground truth you could say well
let's look at the actual tables that
have been generated but those are
generated from data that's been imputed
using the current mechanism so what
we're trying to do is set something up
based on the you know we don't want to
use the current ACS to do this because
the values that come out of this are
based on the existing allocation process
and
[Music]
and right not a kind of uniformly drawn
random sample there's all kinds of
additional things that come in that make
this comparison difficult
our goal instead is to say let's make a
model based on this 1940 census data set
where we presumably have reasonably
complete data
let's make grab the allocation flags
unfortunately we really don't we don't
have the same type of allocation flags
in that data we we've looked for looked
at those and from what we can tell they
don't they don't give us the same type
of information as we have in the 2016
data and the other problem is yeah so so
that's that's yeah and there's some
other there's some other issues like the
1940 census data
I believe it wasn't originally machine
readable format and so there's little
issues with how how it got translated
into that was a major collaborative
project yes yes yes yeah and so there's
a lot that there's a lot that went into
that I'm just surprised that there
aren't any allocation
yeah yeah well that's that's something
we we look for and there are still some
some challenges in in understanding
exactly what some of that because they
oh they have some other flags that are
there in there but I do we don't see
allocation flags that correspond to the
types of allocations that are done with
the modern the recent data but what
we're doing instead is trying to model
so that we can say let's take the 1940
census data and generate a version that
has missing data where it's the it's
missing in ways that are statistically
similar to the way our current data has
missing values because we know from
allocation flags what is missing and
been imputed in those data sets if we
can model that kind of missing then we
get something that's probably more
useful because the the way the data is
collected today is different from the
way it was collected in 1940 even
knowing how it was missing then is
probably not a good model for how it's
missing today and we can at least treat
this as a known ground truth again
at least the errors or where it's not
true are not tied so much to the
imputation method and the hope is our
goal is to use this as a testbed so we
can try to come up with a you know graph
like this here's what you might expect
the distribution to be if we were to
using use this allocation here's what
you would expect it to be if you were to
just ignore the missing data where she
is does it look like that or does it
look like this over here you might say
well you know there's what I assume my
true answer is and yeah maybe I'm better
off taking something where I've done
this imputation even though my variance
is higher I'm still probably going to be
closer to the true answer or maybe it's
something like this where yeah maybe
you're actually likely to be closer to
the true answer just accepting the bias
and ignoring the ignoring the missing
data
we don't know what that's going to look
like and that's our hope is that we can
use this as an approach to just to say
here's what you would expect using
different methods because that's one of
the difficulties the ACS is putting in
is because they don't have the same sort
of constraints and restrictions
but the there there's a lot of work that
is done to get very accurate unbiased
results and some of those things are
very challenging to accomplish and still
satisfy the privacy requirements
and we want to provide tools for people
to evaluate those trade-offs understand
them present them make the decisions as
to what are the appropriate methods to
use
some other challenges and that we've
been running into with trying to look at
some of the research issues that come up
in formal privacy for ACS well the
existing processes are well understood
or at least accepted and so there is
resistance to change and so you want to
explain what that change would mean what
is the cost of formal privacy under the
current processing approach is it
reasonable if not why
john needs to make changes to things and
needs to push for changes to be able to
say as he's done with the database
reconstruction look we've got a problem
we can show you we have a problem are
there you know other than the database
reconstruction as he pointed out this is
not something we need to do again but
there are you know there's there's other
problems that come up and so we want to
be able to address those what are the
costs imposed by alternatives you have
various ways achieving of achieving
formal privacy which is the right one to
use how do you decide in particular
we've been looking at things where we
can say it looks like you have a
bias-variance tradeoff you try to reduce
bias you're doing this in ways that
require you to add more noise to satisfy
formal privacy and you get this
trade-off
the stratified sampling that is used in
collecting ACS data this looks quite
manageable but some of the things they
do in terms of waiting to conform to
known ground truths there are some real
problems there we're achieving formal
privacy with what we know today we're
not certain how to do it this is similar
to the sort of constraint problems that
Dan was talking about but kind of on a
different scale and so are
is that we'll be able to come up with
some good arguments as to why some of
these techniques that are really getting
high sensitivity are actually not
tractable to solve with formal well
maintaining formal privacy and that
would we should be developing new
techniques techniques that we can show
will give both formal privacy and very
good results so anyway that's a that's
kind of what we've been working on this
is very preliminary results I will point
out we're in the process of trying to
get some of the evaluation out the door
so that we can get this written up as an
interesting interesting paper I think
just simply saying we can do smooth
sensitivity for K nearest neighbor is
while it was challenging it's not as
exciting by itself as saying how does
this actually impact a real-world
problem
so we want to be able to say something
about that questions before
[Applause]
you look like John looks like he's ready
to okay this is a really good example
how a team can deep dive into the
agency's high-profile products notice
that each step of it the challenge
applying formal privacy seems
overwhelming so I actually liked your
conclusion which is basically that you
can't go ahead and try to re-engineer
this so that each step you get two steps
like the missing data systems what
you're observing is algorithms that
somebody understood yeah so as best
practice being carried forward no one
touches them because they're in the
production system but they don't even
approximate what you would do if you
read you the system man yeah I think you
listen
basically father every every place you
go one piece of good news is though of
those control weights at the end of the
process that you are worried about those
will actually be different take private
over this next next decades when we're
all that helps us yes controlling
but I do think the right answer is if
you look at the output what is it you're
trying to put the information product
you're trying to conduce and then you
have all of these inputs and then strip
away the historical statistical
processing of those inputs and evaluate
the outputs feasible normally private
methods some of the good things that
were done historically can be preserved
in there some of them are gonna be
swamped by the millions that the formal
privacy gave so you just give up
memories right yeah and I think the key
thing is being able to answer that
question as you know people done these
things in some cases for very good
reasons and others for less good reasons
and where they're doing it for a good
reason
how does this impact us and as we come
up with a new approach whether you know
their words to say okay here's a way
where we can do this missing data
imputation that accomplishes the same
goals but does so in a way that we can
actually come up with something
formally private versus you know a
simple mechanism of just ignoring it
versus some other approach that we
haven't thought of but somebody out here
may think of that that allows us to
address this how do we compare these in
a way that someone can say yes this is
what we want to use and that's that's
really our hope is to be able to not
just come up with ways to solve the
problem but ways that policymakers can
answer that question certainly in the
census all of this processing and
imputation this is all going to happen
before you end up with the
with the disclosure policies so is this
still a problem if it's done if you
treat this is real data no and then you
put that into the but the question is as
we push the place at which the privacy
filter is placed deeper into the
organization what operations come under
the control of the privacy last question
so the the census operations that you
heard the first two talks discussed we
made a very early policy decision when
the final version of the confidential
data were delivered to the score
avoidance system they would be treated
as if those were the actual responses of
each of those households so that says
that the privacy filter doesn't push
into the organization that is an option
with the American Beauty survey but as
Chris's group has noted it's not as
simple more complex multistage
probability samples and their associated
estimates to say that the privacy filter
is at the point at which you're
computing the assessments and you don't
compute them all at once and be some of
the things you do to compute them are
properly considered last step they
should be subjected to the privacy
filter so so if you could push the
privacy over all the way back to the
beginning of the class from ingestion of
the original survey responses then this
sequential composed approach that
Christine was taking would be a viable
alternative but as he notes there are so
many places at which you have to infuse
more noise them
how to control at the moment that the
final output when compared to other
peaceful alternatives is not clearly
better that's it it's the other feasible
alternatives that are harder to develop
because they need your re-engineering a
production system that already has its
estimation and other assumptions built
into that bits and it was a huge thing
to try to fight off a single yeah I
think the key thing is that so much of
what is done basically include increases
sensitivity some cases by small
tractable or at least bound bull amounts
but in other cases by amounts where
there's essentially unbounded increase
in sensitivity
I mean we've run into some things where
it's like well if we were to try to
bound this what can we do well it turns
out there's a hard implementation
imposed limit because somebody use a
particular field width and that's the
best we can could do using the current
process you know obviously that's not
the way you want to go but it's so their
current method is this hot dec
imputation which essentially once
someone is a donor they get removed from
that list of potential donors for a
period of time and then they go back in
so if you hot deck imputation at the
Census Bureau okay for historical
reasons except on surveys like the
current population survey where the
production time schedule doesn't permit
having the entire survey in hand
so they aren't actually started up with
historical values you know imputation
meters so but the ACS is is cold dick
okay yeah yeah and the census is also
called that computed by the standard
definitions now that that said as I as
is pointed out earlier simply even
saying you're never going to reuse a
donor doesn't actually reduce your
sensitivity the from a global
sensitivity point of even a local
sensitivity point of view because you
get this strange problem of removing
someone with from the set of possible
donors affects everyone after them and
so you know whether how that first one
occurs how that first matching occurs
could potentially affect everything
afterwards because if you use this
person now you can't reuse them again
well if you have them to reuse again
maybe you'd use them here which means
you use somebody different here and so
forth so that by itself doesn't change
one of the things to make this nearest
neighbor approach work is to ensure that
there was no such situating possible and
there's some little tricks under the
covers to make sure that happens that
are kind of fairly trivial not not worth
going into in detail but that's that's
one of the difficulties is that if you
want to do this imputation it really
needs to be done in a way where it's not
the fact because it's not just the fact
you may have that you may be the donor
in multiple cases that increases the
sensitivity it's the fact that a change
in the database can cause a big change
in the outcome of a query that that
causes the problem
so again like like I say what we may
well come up with is saying this is
something you don't want to do that you
get you you get better results if you
don't worry about this anyway
[Applause]